you think bitcoin's gonna hit a million
dollars
yeah definition yeah i'm gonna pull my
bullet right so yeah
i i'm assuming you still own a large
amount of bitcoin
i don't personally own bitcoin uh what
i'm
yeah i'm on like i'm inside the industry
right like for for someone outside in
this i'll be like yeah own bitcoin i
believe in bitcoin but i get to take
a lot more risk so if bitcoin is
truexing
i i'd want to be in something that's
10xing got it
so you think the appreciation of bitcoin
is going to be slower going forward
than other opportunities you have in
front of you definitely yes the number
gets like people have the psychology
like
like as the number gets bigger maybe you
know people
people tend to invest in other things so
tell me uh do you think that
there is an opportunity for bitcoin to
be replaced by a better
technology because if you were to say
this to somebody
who is a bitcoin maximalist they would
freak out
and just absolutely lose their mind but
in every other aspect of technology
we see technology being replaced by the
next thing it's very rare that a
technology
or any standard uh stays forever i mean
we do have some examples of ones that
have been around for a while like
the open web or email these are
standards that have
lasted decades but typically speaking
things get replaced with something
better
so what do you think the chances are
bitcoin gets replaced with something
that's much better and what would that
look like in your mind
um very i i feel like there's very low
probability that bitcoin gets replaced
not because it's superior technology
again right like it's it's a
single-celled
organism and and that's where we started
but what we should understand is
blockchain is not about the tech it's
about the narrative
and the story so the blockchain is
you have to analyze and understand
blockchain it's very political
and and a more uh of uh
you know like you you have to do a
religious study about it
then an economical study or a
technological study about it
so bitcoin um winning and bitcoin
staying the top
currencies is for the good of everyone
because if we can break
bitcoin that means that everything else
can be broken too and and that means
that
the base of this whole movement is
always shaky
so it's in the it's in the best interest
of everyone
in the it in the bitcoin or not to make
sure that you know bitcoin wins so it's
like that so even for me
even if i'm directly not invested in
bitcoin i'm
always you know talking about bitcoin
and and and and
making sure that people and like enjoy
bitcoin and from there they take the
other risks
because my point is you cannot talk
about the other cryptos story
origin story without talking about
bitcoin and that gives it
that gives it the value so
it even if there's a better
technological
solution something that operates much
more efficiently or provides other
benefits that bitcoin doesn't and
bitcoin doesn't
adopt those features quick enough you
still believe that everybody should
support bitcoin
because if bitcoin did collapse or get
replaced
um it would cause a contagion within
crypto and people would lose faith in
the crypto industry
yeah that's good i know so you're
describing basically like a cult
or religion it and you you kind of use
the term religion right
you believe bitcoin is a religion more
than a technology
that's that's why i started like uh a
little before i was saying
there are so many analogies we can go by
and every analogy is a little wrong
so yes that's most but the most right
one
for you for bitcoin is religion
definitely definitely
so religion first technology second and
maybe utility maybe third
like technology may in in case of
bitcoin is maybe third
it will be economics right like in this
on the second level yeah
if bitcoin were to stutter or fail
what would be the cause of that you
think because we did have discussions
early on
hey china is going to come out with its
digital currency
other uh countries are going to have uh
their own digital currencies and they
could of course
regulate bitcoin to the level that it
would be not economical
they could put a tax on mining they
could put a tax on using they could
basically tax it or ban it out right and
we haven't actually seen that happen
have we
hm i don't think china would take that
route
right like if china has to be more um
machiavellian
what they would do is they will let
mining really flourish and then try to
fireball attack the whole
bitcoin system and and probably china
would
like you know like they are in the best
situation to pull that off
uh compared to you know trying to shut
it censor it because
that does not makes a lot of sense for
them um but
i don't i don't believe uh like a cbdc
is going to uh stop uh you know like
or the interest that's on bitcoin will
be like reduced because of cbdc it's
very
very hard but yes the countries are
going to try very hard
but cross cross country relationships
right now
are becoming harder and harder and i
feel like
like we have to understand bitcoin from
a context of of of
governments which are which are not in a
very good position right so
so there is there are there are there
are countries in the world like the us
where where it's fine the
system is fine singapore the system is
fine but
it's not the same in in the rest of the
world and i think that's where bitcoin
is winning right like it
it's it's it's some it works very well
in a country at a time and then you know
there's another country for its use case
and
and this keeps going on and people have
this narrative built in their head so
you know it's it's just easy you can
just
remember it very well and and you go for
it so that's going to keep happening
what what do you think the um
pieces of bitcoin that are going to be
um or the aspects of bitcoin that need
to evolve
or that new currencies are going to just
do much
better so
the the the scalability right like
especially the transactions and
um i feel like what we have today i've
been recommending
if i have to go recommend defy to
someone today right uh it's not bitcoin
right and and i i'm also very reluctant
to recommend ethereum
because it's like hundred dollars a
transaction and and someone who has
thousand dollars i really want to tell
them don't put your money in the bank
you can you can convert that into usdc
and then probably you know like make ten
percent and maybe some
some more tokens which are given for
free instead of buying bitcoin
but the thing is they to do that they
have to spend 100 200
transaction so i think that's very
important to be solved
where you know the transaction fees is
something that's
very low like a sub dollar and and
that's when
we really get the crowdson